un demi million de morts et un hommage
national ce lundi joe biden a observé
une minute de silence devant la maison
blanche accompagné de sa vice-présidente
kamala harris
il a symboliquement commémorer les cinq
cent mille décès américains duo kobe de
19 avec notamment cinq cents bougies
placées sur le balcon et les marches de
la résidence officielle
le chef d'état démocrate a ordonné la
mise en berne des drapeaux américains
sur tous les bâtiments fédéraux pour les
cinq prochains jours pays le plus touché
au monde par la pandémie
les etats-unis ont perdu l'équivalent de
la totalité de la population de l'île de
malte
each day a aussi vu ce mois encore elle
ne veut pas que sur chaque jour je
reçois une petite carte dans la poche
j'ai avec moi mon emploi du temps
elle indique le nombre d'américains qui
ont été touchés ou qui sont morts du
côté de 19
aujourd'hui nous marquons une étape
vraiment sinistre et déchirante 500000
71 morts c'est plus d'américains qui
sont morts en un an dans cette
pandémique dans la première guerre
mondiale
la seconde guerre mondiale et la guerre
du vietnam réuni ses plus de vies
perdues à cause de ce virus que dans
n'importe quelle autre nation sur terre
mais alors que nous reconnaissons
l'ampleur de cette mort massive en
amérique
souvenez-vous de chaque personne et de
la vie qu'elle a vécu un bilan humain
tragique mais une note d'espoir tout de
même avec une baisse des nouveaux cas et
de la moyenne hebdomadaire des morts ces
dernières semaines selon les autorités
sanitaires du pays
cette amélioration est constante par
rapport au mois de janvier
nous voyons une baisse continue des cas
de copie de 19 depuis cinq semaines avec
des infections 10 millions de 69% depuis
un pic atteint le 11 janvier pour le
moment plus de 61 millions de personnes
ont reçu une première dose du vaccin
le coronavirus aux états unis le pays
reste leader mondial en la matière
devant la chine ou encore le royaume uni
objectif des autorités américaines
obtenir les doses nécessaires pour
vacciner l'ensemble de la population
d'ici fin juillet